as a woman I have always been respected  by my bosses I always had a lot of  support of the public and I never had  the feeling that they don't accept a  woman as chief in the beginning twenty  years ago when I started in the local  police it was more difficult madjoe what  I see is that women in charge in  different organization they are  listeners and people come to us it's  very important to listen to my people  who are ears and my eyes on the street  every day when I started six or seven  years ago in my position as commissioner  general I thought the last ceiling is  broken now but it wasn't true it's still  often the case that young women make the  choice for the family and not for the  career but you have to find a balance  and you have to help them to find the  balance  you